[Music]
foreign
do
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
my
team
hi welcome to the table
uh this is doc my don jacobs and i'm
just so thrilled that you guys are
all here at this interesting time we
don't normally meet at this time
but because of just kind of special
circumstances that are happening today
we are thankful that you are here to
join us um
so a couple of things i was we were
talking about earlier this week
we were talking about our values um just
here at the table we're
um just a reminder that we're thoughtful
inclusive
eclectic vulnerable and communal
um and and that's important because uh
we do
have to help foster some of that
especially the kingdom of heart we do
have meetups uh that you can take a part
of
if you have not already been hearing
about this already
uh you should but there's one that we
want to miss this definitely high for
this particular week
it's about our teenage girls
this is actually hosted by maggie porter
and maggie tilford
and they host this on wednesday evenings
about 7pm
and they're primarily virtually doing
google hangouts especially during this
cold weather
occasionally they do try to meet in
person when
weather is cooperating but if that's
something you're interested
in make sure you contact them um and
give them a shout out they will be happy
to get you guys connected
um i do want to get this into you
because it is
black history month um and i do did want
to highlight
um one amazing person
that has uh did some great work uh this
is actually by
howard thurman and this is a benediction
that i found
that i felt like kind of led into some
of that work this is the worship that
we're reviewing today
but he actually was actually in very
influential
influence by martin luther king jr's
work
um he was actually born um
in the 1800s and
he just did a lot a lot of excellent
work he was a great
author um just went a great writer
uh good speaker and i saw this and i was
like this this is a good spot
so just want to share this with you
it says it's lord lord open unto me
open unto me light for my darkness
open unto me courage for my fear
open unto me hope for my despair
open up to me peace for my turmoil
open up to be joy for my sorrow
open unto me strength for my weakness
open unto me wisdom for my confusion
open unto me forgiveness for my sins
open unto me tenderness for my tennis
open unto me love for my hates
open unto me thyself
for myself lord
lord open unto me amen
good afternoon it's super bowl sunday i
say that like i'm excited i don't even
know who's in the super bowl you guys
but nevertheless i'm excited
[Music]
yay sports fall as our friend ryan tells
it
um so this week brett's talking about
um serving and giving out of a place of
joy
and as i was thinking about that i feel
like
the times that i do that the best are
the times where i feel like i have been
taken care of
well and loved well um and when i
can ground myself in that love of god
that's with me
in every season that acceptance and that
identity that he gives me when i am
grounded in that that i'm able to serve
even even if sometimes you know it's not
the ideal scenario
i can still serve out of that place of
gratitude and joy and
um excitement so that's kind of the
theme
um you might hear threads of that woven
throughout the lyrics and some of the
songs that i chose for today
um and for a lot of us i feel like it's
helpful
at least for me to think about
relationships in my life
where i feel like that is like on
display where i have been loved where
well where i've been taken care of and
um
some people that immediately come to
mind it's like my aunt debbie if you
guys have ever met her before
she is just like encountering a hug
it's like a relationship with a hug she
can anticipate
our needs before we sometimes even know
what they are
and um also people in our community like
nikki parker if you know nikki uh
then you have been loved well because
that's just who she
is um adam adam is amazing
at uh serving and blessing others and
being thoughtful and
providing for people when they're in
need or just blessing them with gifts
and words of encouragement and always
just showing gratitude and
just i don't know it's it's such an
encouragement to know adam
i feel like um kelly tilford is another
person
she doesn't even live in texas but she
has been a part of our
table community from afar and she's one
of those people in my life that's just
she takes care of us that's just who she
is so
anyways um if you want to reflect on
some relationships where you have
tangibly encountered the love and the
care of god
then um i hope you'll do that maybe that
will
be a good connection point during this
set so we're gonna get started
[Music]
so why should i be
cause you take good care of me
you take good care of me
you don't know what i need before right
hold me in your hands with the kindness
that never ends
i'm carried in your love no matter
what the future brings can you take good
care
of me
the sons
[Music]
the light's not thinking about the
darkness or the shadow that it has
[Music]
so why should i
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
cause be take good care of me
you take good care of me
you know what i
[Music]
in your need with the kindness
you take good care of me
[Music]
with the kindness that never ends
i'm carried in your love no matter what
the future brings
you take good care of me
take good care
[Music]
me
i've heard a thousand
[Music]
stories
as you tell me
[Music]
it's who you are
it's who i am
[Music]
it's who you say
[Applause]
[Music]
it's who is
you am perfect
you are perfect in all of your ways
[Music]
two
can hardly
i can hardly think as you go
deeper still as you hold
me deeper still as you call me
[Music]
it's who you are
who i am
[Music]
how he loves us
oh how he loves us
how he loves us so
how he loves us
[Music]
oh
i don't have time to maintain these
regrets when i think about
the way he loves us
[Music]
oh
loves
[Music]
how he loves us
love oh how he loves us
how he loves
he us us
how he loves us so
[Music]
yes god thank you for being the kind of
god that loves
not a god of shame
not a god of disappointment god
you are not one to separate yourself
from us
despite our mistakes our shortcomings
our lack of understanding even when we
portray you or interact with you as
something other than who you really
are you are faithful and good and kind
to continue to meet us with grace and
love and redemption
god you keep rewriting our story we
invite you into them
ground us in your love
thanks for being who you are help us to
love
others out of that place it's in your
hey good evening everyone grace and
peace
welcome to the table uh it's really
really great to be with you
so we are in part five of our
series titled epiphany a radical
invitation
and the uh really the idea of the season
of epiphany in the church calendar is
that it's a time to reflect on who
christ was and is who he reveals god to
be
and uh really what our response to that
revealing is so
you can see that in many ways epiphany
the season of epiphany is the perfect
follow-up to
christmas um and in the season of advent
because
advent is all about waiting and
receiving something from god that we do
not work for or earn it's really a
season of
um kind of contemplation of grace but
epiphany's slightly different it's
really about our response
as the church to the gift of jesus uh
which is why
it has traditionally come after the
christmas season so
uh with that in mind the title of my
message
uh this afternoon is overflow
overflow we have a a few different
scripture readings
um and the first is from isaiah 40
verses 28 through 31 the second is from
first corinthians 9
19 and the third is mark 1 29-31 but
i'll go ahead and start with isaiah it
says do you not know
have you not heard the lord is the
everlasting god
the creator of the ends of the earth
he will not grow tired or weary in his
understanding
no one can fathom he gives strength to
the weary
and increases the power of the weak
even youths grow tired and weary
and young men stumble and fall
but those who hope in the lord will
renew their strength
they will soar on wings like eagles they
will run and not grow weary
they will walk and not be faint
it's a very famous passage from isaiah
it's quite poetic and beautiful
so the second one is first corinthians 9
19.
paul writes for though i am free
from all i have made myself a servant
to all and then finally mark chapter 1
and immediately jesus left the synagogue
and
entered the house of simon and andrew
with
james and john now simon's mother-in-law
lay ill with a fever
and immediately they told him jesus
about her
and so he came and he took her by the
hand and lifted her
up and the fever left her and she began
to serve them so
uh one of the great spiritual
disciplines in the christian tradition
is the practice of service of of serving
others this of course springs you know
directly from christ himself who in a
variety of places and times
both spoke to this practice um and even
modeled it
um so in his speaking there's the famous
passage
from matthew chapter 20 verse 28
where he said the son of man that was
referring to himself
the son of man did not come to be served
but to serve
now because that's on jesus lips like
and we sort of expect him to say things
like that it may not sound all that
um surprising or remarkable but if you
pause and think about it jesus was the
type of person
who others would have been happy to
serve
he was charismatic and likable
he was very powerful and could engage
the miraculous
he had a certain presence about him
um kind of you know carrying a sense of
authority he had a large
following of people everywhere he went
he's like a rock star or something
uh and yet it was him
he said i did not come to be served
but to serve another example is from
matthew chapter 23 verse 11 where the
disciples are
um basically they're all arguing over
who among them will be the greatest
in the afterlife typical
ego argument and so jesus says
well let me settle this for you the
greatest among you
and i'm sure they're all just on the
edge of their seats uh-huh uh-huh
it's me the greatest among you
is the servant of all
what a deflating kind of the greatest
among you
is the servant among you
in other words if you want to be great
lay down your life and serve
uh and then finally in terms of his
example his actual living
there's a famous story from john chapter
13 uh where jesus
after a very long day of walking
and remember the roads in the ancient
world were like not roads like we think
of
i mean they were basically non-existent
um it was really mostly dirt paths that
people walked
and they wore sandals and so they were
in the dust and dirt and mud and
of course they're like animal droppings
on the path so their feet were
were pretty nasty after day's walk and
so at the end of the day the 12
disciples and jesus they all gather in a
room for
a meal when suddenly jesus gets up from
his seat
gathers a towel in a wash basin and one
by one proceeds to
wash all uh 12 well really 24
of the disciples feet
this was a job normally reserved for the
servant of the house or for the lowest
drinking person
in the room which apparently
none of them wanted to admit to bean so
everyone's feet had gone unwashed and so
uh jesus um he does this he washes their
feet and then after he
finished he asked them this he said do
you know what i've done for you
and it was pretty clearly a rhetorical
question because they were silent
and then he continued you call me
teacher and lord
and rightly so now that i the lord
have washed your feet you also
ought to wash one another's feet
and so generations of christians have
have really understood this story as
it's like a parable of swords like a
living parable
uh in other words it's less about
literally washing each other's feet
i'm guessing you would all feel rather
uncomfortable and awkward if every time
you entered like a fellow christian's
house they just insisted on washing your
feet
um so it's less literal and now we see
it as this
profound metaphor this this profound
example of who we are called to be
we are the foot washing people of the
world
we are the servants of all
uh it's i mean it's a beautiful
statement
very very beautiful uh and and yet
like everything uh
it has its shadow side and here's what i
mean
um it has been misunderstood
it has been at times misused
and even abused i mean sometimes even by
like manipulative church leaders who say
things like
well you can't say no to helping the
church you can
you can't turn this down you're a
follower of christ
the servant of all and furthermore
you're to submit to your spiritual
authority
me but uh
let me see you can see there how that
can get kind of like
i mean it's like technically yes you are
quoting jesus
but there's something about this
interaction that feels a little off
um but it's it's not always church
leaders and i don't mean to imply like
that's all church leaders are all doing
that all the time
i don't i hope that's not the case um
but you know sometimes though it's not
even about just leadership or something
it's often it's just by well-meaning um
folks but people maybe who are um wired
in a way where they they
really um they're pleasers right they're
they're kind of hungry for love and
hungry for
approval uh and
those folks can often be very tempted
towards a kind of
misunderstanding of um this invitation
to be the servant of all
uh which is why you know when some
people hear statements like
be the servant of all or lay down your
life for
others um what they hear
not necessarily what the bible is saying
but what they hear what they're
interpreting
um sounds something like this so just be
clear this is not i'm not advocating for
this i'm saying this is what people hear
they hear we are the people who
let others walk all over us
uh we are the people who do not know how
to set boundaries
uh we're the people who live in deep
fear of disappointing
others that we are the people who serve
to the point of total depletion
and exhaustion just giving giving giving
giving
and then we serve some more we are the
people who feel chronically guilty
for not doing enough we are the people
who must always say yes to helping
and pretend to love it even though we're
dying a little
inside uh we're the people who believe
that you can never tell the pastor or
the church leader um i'm sorry no i
can't i can't help out there
now um what am i getting at with all
this here's what i'm trying to get at
when the bible speaks of serving others
it is not about serving from a place of
exhaustion
guilt or earning love and approval
that's the key when the bible speaks of
serving others it's not about serving
it's not trying to describe
a servant from this place of exhaustion
guilt or earning love and approval
instead it is about serving from a place
of
rest a sense of calling
and a deep knowing that because
i am loved because i am
valuable because god calls me beloved
son
beloved daughter i am
free i'm free to be the servant of all
without feeling diminished
without having my my sense of agency
robbed from me because no
has been taken off the table like no
that's not christian service
instead the idea is that when we come
into alignment with christ
with the holy spirit our service this
sense of service it begins to bubble up
from within from the soul
from strength from from a sense of
faith hope and love
can you hear the difference between that
kind of service
and and something like this like well i
better say yes
because if i say no then they may not
love me anymore
or or i just feel i just feel terrible
saying no
so i'll just go ahead and say yes
can you hear the difference between
those two statements and in a type of
service that bubbles
up from within
you see there is a way of serving that
stems from weakness
and insecurity uh however the type of
service that jesus
is both talking about and modeling for
us
is service from a sense of strength
from calling from great love
and gratitude and this is why i
love our scriptures for today coming
back to isaiah
40 starting in verse 30 this time even
youths grow tired and weary
young men stumble and fall but those who
hope in the lord
will renew their strength they will soar
on wings like eagles they will run and
not grow weary they will walk
and not be faint here's my question what
would it look like
if your service was a form of soaring
of thriving of of running
so to speak without growing weary of
walking
forward every day without getting
exhausted
wouldn't that be wonderful but when
you're serving the way god calls you to
serve
that's the sensation that's what it
feels like it's
uh it's not day after day after day of
ugh
it's day after day of this is who i am
this is who god has called me to be
in other words god has called me to a
life
of loving service not exhaustion
burnout and resentment
that's a word for someone resentment if
you are resenting
your service if you're resenting people
uh who you have to serve and by the way
here i'm not just talking about serving
in the church like this is anywhere in
your life
if you're resenting your service uh then
something is off
that that is not the life god has called
you to
and um and by the way i'm not saying the
problem is your attitude
that if you just turn that frown upside
down then things would be fine and dandy
uh i mean maybe it's an attitude thing
that's i guess that's the k
that's possible that's the case but
that's not quite what i'm naming i'm
saying
more than likely um you're just not very
good at setting boundaries
and now you're blaming others for it
uh or perhaps blaming god you know here
i am being miserable doing what you told
me to do
um no you didn't call you nope
no it's just uh there's a failure of
boundaries here um
i i speak from experience i personally
have been on such a journey with this
for the last
probably ten years um this is something
i've talked about this quite often in my
messages because
just for those who know me well they
know that well i do i love my work here
at the table
i love it uh i can be
at times driven by insecurity and a fear
of failure
um and i can kind of be pushed by that
into this into a certain mode of
overworking of overextending myself
and then i become the worst version of
myself
often taking out my frustration and
exhaustion not on all of you
because hey i'm you know kind pastor
brett uh instead it is my family
uh who suffers often honestly my kids um
primarily in the evenings when i can
just become a terribly crappy person to
be around
i've been you know better in recent
years with this but
um it used to be quite bad and it's
still it's very much an ongoing battle
so this is like here's kind of a this is
a bit of a silly example
um but here's a moment that replays
we'll just say too
often uh so it's towards the end of my
work week
and you know i'm tired um and someone
from the church or sometimes it's kind
of our extended community
um you know there are folks who kind of
look to the table for like emotional
support
and such maybe don't even attend um but
they've heard about us and we're just in
touch so
someone you know they reach out and they
just need some emotional support so they
call me
and i know you know just based on the
name on my phone i know they're gonna
need something from me
um but it's towards the end of the week
and i'm just i'm exhausted
and i i really i just don't have all
that much
more to give that week have you ever
been there just like
i don't know how much i have to give
here so
there i am i see the name uh and so i
answer
and sure enough you know they they're in
need they need something
and often like it's an emergency they
need it now it's a crisis this
and right now this is like the moment of
truth and they say hey we can we meet
can we meet today and i'm like
of course
[Laughter]
yeah yes uh and i mean i could justify
it
right i mean i'm like um i'm a pastor
and we're supposed to be the servant of
all i mean imagine how much more i'm
supposed to be the servant of all if you
all are supposed to be the servant
with the pastor servant of allah of
course on christ himself
okay that was horrendous i didn't mean
that literally just a joke um
but uh so that's the situation i get
myself into now
what should i have said what should i
have told them
here's what i should have said um you
know
i can tell you really need someone to be
there for you
i mean what that is okay that's fine
sometimes we just need someone
um here's the thing today it just can't
be me
um let me put you in touch with someone
who can help
that's what i should have said because
jesus exhortation
to serve others is not an excuse
for my own immaturity and
people-pleasing and lack of boundary
setting
and what inevitably happens well i i
meet with them and then in that moment
i'm much more the young man growing
tired and weary as isaiah says
than the person renewing my strength and
soaring like an
eagle and that's when i know
i'm doing it wrong that's when i know
uh and of course it's on me it's on it's
not on them just be clear i'm not
blaming oh how could they call me like
no
that's fine uh i have failed to set the
appropriate
boundaries god did not command me to
say yes to everyone uh and i know you
all would be perfectly fine if i said
hey you know what not
nope not right now let's meet next week
you'd be fine um
see this is my issue but i'm learning
i'm learning and honestly i could take a
huge lesson from the apostle paul i love
this passage
we read earlier first corinthians 9 19
paul writes
for though i am free from all
i have made myself a servant to all
isn't that beautiful that's like the
pinnacle of the spiritual life
i am far from the pinnacle um i mean
what a beautiful statement
although although i am free from all
although i don't have to say
yes to anything or anyone
because i know i'm loved i know i'm
worthy i don't
like need people's approval i don't need
them all to be happy with me
i am free but precisely paul says
because i am free i can make
myself the servant of everyone i meet
what does he mean
he's saying that he can serve anytime
anywhere anyone
because it does not demean him it does
not make him feel little
or lesser than he's not compulsive
or guilt-ridden or afraid of
disappointing
others in his service you see he resents
no one because he is free
he can say no
and it's precisely because he can say no
because he's free right
that he can also say a true heartfelt
loving yes
yes and when we can operate in that mode
then our service it flows like
oil rather than grinding like
metal on metal gears
which is honestly exactly what our
gospel reading today
from mark chapter 1 verses 30-31
um we'll come back to that now simeon's
mother-in-law lay ill with a fever
and immediately they told jesus about
her and so he came and took her by the
hand and lifted her up
in the fever left her and she
began to serve them i don't imagine
that when she awoke from her fever um
and found she had been healed by jesus
i i doubt that she then thought to
herself like
oh great oh we have guests
oh more people needing things from me
i don't know i don't think that's it at
all is that i imagine
that simon peter's mother-in-law was
overjoyed
to live right suddenly the world was
bright and beautiful
again i mean you know what it's like to
recover from a sickness
uh we've spent enough time in bed like
let's get
up so i imagine she was energized and
because god had done great things for
her
she began to serve out of the overflow
that's how our service should be it's
springing up from within
from a place of joy from gratitude let
me sum it up like this
when we serve from the overflow
our service flows easily and lovingly
when we serve from the overflow what do
i mean by overflow i mean from
grace from a sense of calling
from love from as paul talked about
freedom
then our service flows easily
and lovingly all right so what's the
what's the takeaway
how how should you live differently in
light of this
message um so my hunch is that you need
to ask yourself
these two questions number one
what do i need to let go of
in other words where have i been serving
with a growing sense of resentment
rather than freedom what what do i need
to maybe
delegate or say no to and this could be
um at work this could be at home um
this could you know be at church like if
you're doing something
and it is gears grinding metal on
metal you are depleted and you are
growing resentful
again as i said earlier you're not doing
the lord's work or at least you're not
doing it in the right way that's that's
not what jesus is talking about
so ask yourself okay what do i need to
let go of
or what do i need to rethink here i mean
because maybe it's just that you need to
do
less of that thing you're still going to
do the thing it's just i need to
i need to back this off um and then go
ahead and schedule
a conversation um with the appropriate
person so that's the first question
okay what do i need to let go of
a second question what do i need
to take up see this is about
prioritizing who or what
are you called to give attention to
right now in this season of life
because it shifts and changes over time
right and sometimes you're like holding
on to something
from the past it's like oh i just can't
give that up
and it's gears grinding metal on metal
and meanwhile
it's because god's calling you to this
new thing so okay what what do i
what am i called to give attention to
now in this season what
what would be the place of great joy
um for you to serve
and then start moving towards those
people
or that thing um one way to think about
it is
go where the grace is go where the
energy is go where the
joy is amen
all right so in place of a prayer
i wanted to take 60 seconds to thank
some very special people for their
service in this season so
to all of the teachers uh who have had
your routines and rhythms
upended by this pandemic and you have
been willing to sit with our kids
each day and put yourself at risk so
that they can learn
we see you and we are so
incredibly grateful for the health care
workers
thinking of doctors nurses
other staff at hospital in clinton
hospitals and clinics doctor's offices
um as well as all the first responders
we have a number of those
at the table um you are
i mean y'all are right on the front
lines of everything with this
pandemic battle and again we're so
incredibly grateful for your service
we love you um thank you thank you thank
you
and um and now for the folks at the
table to all of our wonderful
behind the scenes folks i'm thinking of
candace frank who does all of our
bookkeeping
uh where would we be without candace i
shudder to think
um and rob macado who actually is
um just join is now starting to oversee
our finance team
um thank you both so much kasha watts
who handles all of our social media
posts
and digital marketing it's not by magic
that those
show up and i'm not doing it um she is
doing it
and so i'm so grateful for you my friend
to all of our volunteers
in meetups y'all a round of applause for
all of our meetup leaders
um here's ones who are presently leading
it's darryl adams
uh with the men's meetup it's maggie
tilford and maggie porter with the team
group
uh karen and gary meyer who are leading
our pandemic support group at sarah
johns and glenda beyron
with our book club uh it's milagros
mikado and nancy purdy with the be the
bridge um racial reconciliation group
uh y'all i mean over the last like 10
months y'all have been
just rocks of connection in an
ocean of disconnection for so
many people thank you for your time and
energy
um we love you and finally brittany
johnson
with kids ministries she's sending out
that weekly newsletter
that you all are getting and many mindy
reynolds for figuring out how to lead
worship online
gary and scott with the tech team
and so many others on that team and i
mean i can just keep going but i just
want to name
uh just thank you thank you thank you
thank you um
even us i think of sarah johns marissa
martinez who are helping with our kind
of
hostess role in the background on sunday
evenings i'm just y'all
we're so blessed i'm so blessed my heart
is full i love this community so
um i just i didn't want a
message on service to you know do the
whole thing without
recognizing there's just many people um
who are currently serving both um in our
church
and um beyond in our community so
um god sees you we see you we love you
all right that's all i got grace
and peace
thanks babe um i couldn't agree with
that more
it made it made me a little bit like
you know emotional as he was naming just
the different people
when i think about your personal lives
and what you're giving up
um you know i think one of the best
things i've ever heard is anytime we say
yes to one thing we're saying no to
another
so to those who of you that brett just
named who
have chosen to show up in those ways
during this time
thank you because it comes at a cost and
it comes with sacrifice
and um i can say this next song that i'm
about to share with you
um is called two and it's from
the enneagram series um
that was written uh by sleeping at last
and um it mindy had asked me to share it
because
i identify as a two on the enneagram and
for those of you who are twos out there
i know
um this message probably hits
really really close to home um
i can say for myself one of my most like
um i don't know if embarrassing's the
right word but
telling moments for sure i remember at
one point
brett and i were serving at our last
church and
um it was just a time where all hands
were needed on deck
but as someone who can sometimes operate
in the unhealthy sides of that
um i was a little out of balance to say
the least and i don't think
it hit me i i was in the place that he
was talking about
where um you start to resent
and you start to feel sorry for yourself
and you feel a little bit entitled
and those things were happening and i'm
just thinking of everyone else who's not
protecting me or looking out for me
or grateful enough for all that i'm
doing i mean that was like what was in
my head
i remember sitting at a leadership
meeting and saying you know that we were
doing a check-in on everyone how are you
doing how's this season going
and i said you know i feel like i would
just cut myself
open and bleed to keep everybody else
happy
in my head before i said that i thought
this is really something to be admired
and then as the words come out of my
mouth i realize
how out of balance it is um
and not necessarily something to be
proud of
and really and truly the only person who
can protect
me in that situation is myself
um but at our best and when we
can operate in health and i love the
language that brett just use
in the strength of that service
and that way of showing love to other
people
um it can be this amazing force in the
world
um that truly gives
not in in a you know
unhealthy way but gives of itself
um for the sake of others and lays their
life down
in a way that can be incredibly
christ-like so
this song is sort of a picture into the
heart behind service
and it kind of exposes both the
unhealthy sides
of it as well as a true attempt to get
to a place where you're doing it
in strength and um
yeah out of a true sense of calling um
an identity so anyways i'm going to
share that
and i hope you guys enjoy it
[Music]
sweetheart you look a little tired
when did you last eat
come in and make yourself right at home
stay as long as you need
tell me if something's wrong if
something's wrong
you can count on me
you know i'll take my heart clean apart
if it helps yours beat
it's so okay if you can't
find the words
let me take your coat and its weight
off of your shoulders
like the force to be reckoned with
mighty ocean or a gentle kiss
i will love you with every single thing
i have
[Music]
if it serves your best i will love you
without
any strings attached
it's okay if you can't
catch your breath
you can take the oxygen right out
of my own chest
i know exactly how your rules go
put my mask on first
no i don't wanna talk about myself
tell me where it hurts
just wanna build you up build
[Music]
i don't even know
where to start
already tired of trying to recall
where it all fell
[Music]
somehow be loved
myself
[Music]
like a force to be reckoned with
mighty ocean original kiss
i will love you without any strings
attached
what a privilege it is to laugh
[Music]
like the force to be reckoned with
mighty ocean original kiss
i will love you without any strings
attached
[Music]
without any strings attached
i will love you without a single string
attached
wow thank you so much for sharing that
with us
uh and also thank you for joining us uh
tonight
uh if you're in need of uh prayer or
support this time
please just message us at the table on
either on facebook
um or in the chat below and we'll just
have one of our leaders
follow up with you and then of course we
want to
encourage you to to give to the table
you can do that at thetabletx.org
that's an easy way to do that and then
as we close tonight i do want to share
this
benediction with you may the blessing of
god go before you
makes grace and peace abound
may god's spirit live within you
may god's love wrap you around
and may god's blessing remain with you
always
may you walk a holy ground amen
be blessed and have a great week see you
next sunday
you